2014's us chess league season has come
to an end and the st. Louis Archbishop's
are shaping up to have their best year
ever by being the champions of the
Southern Division the st. Louis
Archbishop's have earned a spot in the
quarterfinals of the u.s. chess leagues
playoffs so we're the big favorite this
year in Dallas is probably second but
you were pretty solid this year because
the last three or four matches on the
bottom two boards were scoring points
then we're always score importance on
the top two boards because if somehow so
in laQuan can play there's a cobian and
there's me so we always have a GM on the
top two boards if to gm's the season
started with what seemed like money in
the bank as manager Alex marler paired
two powerhouses on boards one and two
with Wesley so and lick wang Li in ok so
like on the top two boards I believe in
20 games we have something like 16 and a
half points so we're killing it and we
weren't doing off the beginning of the
season on boards three and four but
lately with the additions of Matt Larsen
and Spencer Feingold they've been
scoring a lot of points so actually we
won our last three matches by a score of
three to one and I think of its he wants
to beat our team they would have to win
the bottom two boards and somehow drawn
the top two after their result in round
8 the Archbishop's had clinched a spot
in the playoffs when it comes to playing
chess over the Internet it seems like
strictly a one-on-one game but the
players on the Archbishop's would tell
you there is such a thing as team unity
I mean and it's always in team chess
team chemistry is important for example
this is why I like Russia usually
doesn't have a good result and team
tournaments even though often on a four
board team they would have three people
on the top 10 as far as the world
ratings go but he they don't necessarily
it jive very well they don't have good
chemistry and and you can't have that if
in a team we're all like very friendly
and and help each other out and and yeah
we I think we have great chemistry and
that's really going to help us it go
through the playoffs the team's final
regular season game was back on october
twenty eighth when they beat the
carolina Cobras the Archbishop's will
next meet the new jersey knockouts on
wednesday november 12 at seven o'clock
central time I don't think that anybody
could be a definite lock but I think
that were definitely the favorites and
as long as like something crazy doesn't
happen I don't know why we we wouldn't
be a big favorite to join the when the
US chess leave this here the
Archbishop's versus New Jersey knockouts
match is Wednesday November twelfth at
seven o'clock central time you can watch
each game as it happens on the ICC the
internet chess club and catch the live
commentary with grandmaster yasir Sarah
Juan at st. Louis chess club dot org
okay st. Louis we're the center of the
country you playing the center go
Archbishop's